please come in
plenty of suits in the front
and it's safe you know usually at shows
you don't want to see
you don't want to sit in the first row
because you never know what's going to
happen but i can promise it's totally
safe today i won't pick on you or
anything right
even if you if you run python on windows
i won't
okay
yes
uh so thank you very much for showing up
uh it's a pleasure it's a pleasure to be
back in uh
in actual rooms with actual people after
sitting on
on my bottom for two years and watching
zoom people
so thank you for that
thank you london for not being 40
degrees celsius today i just took the
train from paris it's blazing hot you
don't want to come here
you know stay in london it's raining
very safe all right
so my name is julian
and i work for a company you may have
heard of it's called hugging face
and uh we built this thing called
transformers
and that's what i'm gonna talk about
today so i have a few slides to get the
party going just a few i promise and
then we'll start running some demos okay
so before we get started who here has
never ever worked with transformers and
it's okay all right
i barely know the stuff okay all right
who's running production workloads on
transformers
okay a few all right and everybody's is
kind of in the middle okay
all right so hopefully everybody will
learn something today
good
um
so you know we like to oversimplify
things and you know i'm no different so
i guess deep learning kind of started
uh i mean technically it was there in
the in the 40s but i think it kind of
exploded onto the stage uh you know
2012 and onwards
when people started using gpus for more
than uh shooting each other in video
games
which was still a good thing to do i
guess
and that's what i call deep learning to
zero so back then uh what made deep
learning possible was hey neural
networks became cool again after decades
of being totally
um you know unusable
because of
lack of computing power lack of
scalability etc so neural networks
convolutional networks recurrent neural
networks became hot again
and people started solving complex
problems with those
obviously we needed some data for that
and we had a few open data sets right
and of course the king of them all was
imagenet back then with the imagenet
competition and so all of a sudden
all those phds out there got obsessed
with you know recognizing dogs and cats
and elephants
which probably was a refreshing change
from their daily work
um
but anyway that got the you know that
got the interest and people could
understand okay so ai is actually able
to
comp understand complex data complex
features
um putting the two together of course
would not be very good if you didn't
have gpus and you know massive computing
power to do that and you know cloud
computing made it reasonably easy and
cheap i guess inexpensive to grab those
gpus for a couple of hours train some
models et cetera et cetera
whoops and the last bit
was of course tools
and i think that's where the problem was
and
maybe it still is for a lot of folks
right
expert tools
so who wants to tell me here that like
the first few versions of tensorflow or
fianna were user friendly no
no no
they were great they were much better
than the alternative which was hey let's
write everything from scratch ourselves
but they were still very very hard to
use and so those
initial set of open source libraries
were
you know they were not for the average
developer
and i mean that in a you know in a very
positive way you really needed some deep
machine learning background and computer
science background to get them working
still some people got some work done
although a lot of people got the feeling
that hey you know this deep learning
thing is not really delivering right
and so everybody went to work and
[Music]
well i think
things have changed a little bit now so
i'm calling this 2-0
i'm i'm really hoping it's not 1.1 but
we'll see in a few years but you know we
see some progress
of course
you know i'm not gonna lie uh the main
thing for us at hogging face is
transformers um
and everybody here in the room has heard
of bert um google bert and and and the
the follow
the following models and these are
really you know broken all those
state-of-the-art benchmarks and they
keep breaking them
and this transformer architecture just
has proven very efficient
much more efficient than anything that
came before like cnns and lstms
initially
on natural language processing
but now increasingly on computer vision
and speech
and
reinforcement learning
and all kinds of different new tasks
so this is really we think a significant
step
instead of building crazy large data
sets which no one really likes right
raise your hand if you like labeling and
cleaning data four days a week
all right
good
you're smart people in london i knew
that
um yes
we use transfer learning instead okay so
somebody has built those massive data
sets
um
and they don't need to be particularly
clean either because transformers are
kind of robust to to unclean data
and they've pre-trained them on large
gpu clusters generally
and
they kind of give them away to the
community right so now you can grab your
you know your bert or your roberta or
your t5 model and it's been pre-trained
and maybe you can use it as is or maybe
you just fine-tune it a little bit and
this is called transfer learning okay so
the benefit here is you don't need to
label millions of data instances
and you don't need to spend
hundreds of thousands of dollars to
train those models from scratch you can
just reuse existing models
gpus are still around of course and i'm
sure a lot of people here use gpus on a
daily basis
but
you know as great as they are they've
never been designed for machine learning
although
now they're kind of catching up
and we see a new generation of chips
that are being
specifically designed and built and
optimized for machine learning workloads
either for training or inference and
i'll i'll talk about that a little later
so that's another benefit and finally
you know we at hugging face are pushing
very very hard with the help of the open
source community to build software tools
that everybody can use
right so if you're an expert that's
great you can still tweak to death
but you know if you're the average joe
or the average jane and you just know a
little bit of python
and you want to try and plug in some
machine learning magic into your app
well now it's much much easier than it
was before
and you know we try and keep uh
improving that so that's that's the
vision we have and that's what we're
trying to build
so more than anything else you you may
know hogging phase for the transformers
library um which is uh
one of the fastest growing open source
projects indeed where you hopefully you
can see that you wear the yellow line on
the left so the one with the steepest
slope
and these are get up stars as you
figured out
and uh i think now we're past 65 000
stars so thanks everybody and if you
haven't starred the repo you know what
to do next
so that in my next talk i can say 66 000
and we keep going
and what's interesting is
um
and i was actually surprised when i
built this it's like we're growing
faster than kubernetes
it's like who i mean seriously
like no offense to all the really
awesome machine learning and
and you know database projects in there
but i kind of thought hey yeah we're
growing bigger than those
and there are lots of reasons for that i
mean the the maturity and
i mean github usage for once is a factor
too but
but kubernetes and uh and node
well that's pretty cool
so it shows we have a lot of adoption so
thank you everybody for for
trusting us and using us
and this is being picked up by you know
also analyst reports so the state of ai
report which i'm sure you've read
says that very early it's actually one
of the key things in the report that
transformers are becoming a general
purpose solution
so um
so i you know i'm not tired of doing
those nlp talks actually we'll do nlp
again today
but uh you know again computer vision
and speech and every a lot of other use
cases work very very well with
transformers
and and the kaggle uh data science
survey kind of echoed this
um they showed the popularity of algos
and uh in the kaggle community and we
see rnns cnn's going down and
transformers going up so
you know it's a good sign i guess that
deep learning workloads are kind of
shifting to the transformer architecture
so you should learn about it right
not just for kaggle competitions
usage you know people love numbers so uh
that's where we are today we have over 1
million downloads of a million model
downloads every day
and way over 100k hub users every day
and these days is particularly insane uh
who here has tried the dali mini thing
okay yeah there you go so
the infra team is thanking you for very
busy nights
scaling that thing okay
but yeah it's a lot of fun it's a lot of
fun
um so this is what the family picture
looks like it's i try to kind of put
everything on a single page here
and and really what we're striving to do
is to build this very fast
development cycle
that's truly agile right
not disguised you know not waterfall in
these guys
where within a day you know you can go
from hey here's a data set
here's a model
i'm going to fine tune those things
using maybe my infrastructure or cloud
infrastructure and then i'm going to
build a demo of that with spaces which
i'll show you later
and i'm going to deploy it
and i'm going to
evaluate that model in production
and i'm going gonna keep doing that okay
and we really really see our customers
uh uh doing this in in a day right in a
matter of hours sometimes
so you know as i keep telling customers
and execs particularly they tell me yeah
you're okay it's machine learning so
what you know we've been doing machine
learning since 1856
uh and i i'll say well
not this fast uh my friend because you
could have your uh you know stakeholder
meeting on monday morning right
and you can be confident leaving that
meeting that next monday you'll have
something to show
right with a nice safety margin because
this is a very fast way to do machine
learning and you will see in the demo
later we're actually not writing machine
learning code right which is great
because i can't really do that anyway
right
so that's the cycle
that we promote uh using the datasets
library the transformers library the
optimum library which are all open
source
and also you know because we have
customers who use the cloud and aws
we also have a partnership with a stage
maker aws on sagemaker so we have a
very deep integration and actually we
have co
engineering with aws
on sage maker anyone using sagemaker
here on
all right good because you know i was
working for aws before so
i convinced you right yeah
sure
uh and to keep everybody happy we also
have a partnership with uh microsoft
azure this more this one is kind of
recent if you haven't tried it you can
go to the azure marketplace just look
for hogging face
and in a couple of clip clicks sorry
you can actually deploy
any nlp model from the hub any public
model in on a management point and
predict
so if you like azure that's fine
there's one cloud missing from that
picture if anyone is working for that
cloud in the room
you know where to find me okay
if you have friends working there you
know give him my email address
i'm sure they listen
okay so that's the that's the big
picture we're gonna look at
most of these blocks you know a little
quick but you can get all the code later
and and run it
again the one thing i want to
zoom in just for a minute on is hardware
acceleration because usually this
this is not such a well understood topic
and it's becoming more and more
important
and the reason why it's becoming more
and more important is because these
transformer models are huge right
i mean
bert initially you know we all thought
oh this is too big right
now by today's standard bird and
distilled bird they're they're you know
very you know lightweight models
the new models are you know five gigs 10
gigs 20 gigs 30 gigs
uh you know we have those big science
models that we're training with the
community these are going to be hundreds
of gigs okay so
loading
training predicting
is is uh is difficult so
we have this library called optimum
which i really really encourage you to
look at i'll show you a couple of
examples
it's uh it's an open source library that
uh
is based on hardware uh accelerations
the partnerships we have with all those
companies
uh so habana and graphcore for training
and onnx and an intel for inference
and it makes it very easy as you will
see to you know
to train your models or inference with
your models quantizing etc
and we also have uh integration ws with
inferential which is their custom chip
for hardware acceleration on inference
okay so
this is really a problem that you kind
of stumble on when you're in prod
um so those of you who are in product
probably facing that already those of
you who are not will definitely hit that
problem at some point so it's a good
idea to go and check out what optimum
can do and generally you'll learn a
little more about how you can speed up
those models
okay uh that's it for the slides uh
we'll come back to the last one for our
resources but
for now i need to put my glasses on
and we need to start running some code
so
so this is uh
this is actually part of uh
whoops of course i didn't know that
um this is actually part of a workshop
i'm kind of building here uh i'll
probably building it for the next 10
years
you can find all the code here
gitlab.com julian simone
hugging face demos okay
so it has a lot of stuff but i've
decided to pick just a few bits and
pieces okay so in a nutshell what we're
doing here is we're
training a model
to classify amazon product reviews
uh according to the star rating you know
one to five stars
and to kind of scope the problem down a
little bit i'm sticking to shoe reviews
okay
and we're gonna try and go through the
major steps that you would go through uh
if you had to work on that project
yourself okay
um so obviously
you know the first step would be hey
let's go to the hugging face hub where
you have those 53 000 models and those
uh
almost 6 000 data sets it's growing
every day every hour
and and you could say well can we find
something that works out of the box is
there a model ready to go here
and you know i'm sorry to say although
we do have models for quite a few things
here as you can see
uh let me maybe go full screen
you know computer vision and natural
language processing and speech
recognition and
and and more
well we don't have a ready-made model to
classify product shoe reviews
according to star ratings but we have
things that are close enough okay
and in fact we have
we even have a data set
we have the amazon us reviews data set
which we can see
right here
on the hub right
um and it has lots of product categories
and it has shoes
so that's pretty nice right so i can
visualize that data
right there on the hugging face hub and
i can see okay yeah shoes
so that's probably a good starting point
right and if you're a shoe retailer you
know it's safe to say you're going to
have thousands and thousands and
thousands of shoe reviews and you can
use that
but maybe you need to clean the data and
process the data and remember you know
you promise to show something next
monday so you're not going to go and do
that you're going to start from data
that's already there
and that's why we have almost 6 000 data
sets on the hub because it's
you know
data that's ready to go ready to be used
in your project right and so the first
step will be hey i'm going to use that
and build my poc okay
just to show what that
model could look like
and and get some feedback from my
stakeholders right and in the meantime
you can assign you know all the data
science interns to hey here are you know
1 million 1.2 million you know unclean
product reviews and tweets and emails go
and label them
yeah and of course they will all quit
after time sometimes that's why you have
interns right
you gotta learn doing that it's it's a
cleaning data is like the number one
skill yeah
all right so seriously this is what
we're going to do and
of course
we can start working with the
data sets library which is one of our
open source libraries
and loading the data set is as easy as
one line
right
and this downloads this data set from
the hub
you could download it if you had your
own data let's say in amazon s3 or you
know azure storage you could you could
do the same
right
so why don't we run this thing see what
happens
okay
so it's a big one
it's a big one we have four
yeah four million four point three
million so that's too much you could say
oh give me just ten percent
you know i don't need four million to
experiment
and i can look at this data here
okay and
here i can see lots of columns so you
know i'm just going to keep keep it
simple
and of course the star rating is
interesting
and the review itself is interesting so
i'm just going to drop everything
else right
and you can see how simple this data set
api is if you know pandas which i'm sure
you do
uh you'll be very very familiar with
this
right
we can check that we don't have weird
values
you know it should be one to five stars
nothing else
we can see if the data set is balanced
or not and in fact we see we have many
many more five star reviews
than other
star ratings
that's not so good so why don't we
rebalance everything and we keep 20 000
for each star rating right to give the
model a chance to learn right
okay
just a couple of lines of code nothing
more you know this isn't machine
learning it's just python
and then i can build
oh
data sets not imported
all right let's import it
there we go
okay so now we have 100k reviews
and
if you saw this maybe you went wait
this is it right everybody should start
if everything should start at zero not
one so yeah labels need to start at zero
so we can easily decrement them
okay we see how this is this is write
this small function map
map that function to the data sets
now we have everything we need right and
now we have a nice and friendly data set
that has zero labels uh zero to four
and we can split it
for test and validation
and we can save it locally and of course
we can push it to the hub
we can save it in s3 we can do all of
that right actually i've done this
before so
in the interest of time
so here's my data set on the hub
right so you've done that
work you can share it with your team you
can share it with the community you know
all it took was that very simple
notebook and
pushing it to the hub right and if
you've never used hugging face before
this is just a github repository
right
so you can use the open source libraries
to use that to work with that or you can
just use the git workflow and you can
clone from that url here directly
right
so very simple
so now we have a data set
and
we could go and use it to fine-tune
maybe a model right
and here you know uh there was a a talk
earlier today on uh training hugging
face on sagemaker
my train was late and of course i missed
it uh but so yeah i would encourage you
to
to go and look at it if you're using ws
so again this time i'm going to use the
transformers library i'm going to start
from my
good friend the distilbert
model
which i guess i can see on the hub
uh yeah this one here
okay
so
a base language model for english
and this one is just the base model it
hasn't been
set up for the particular task we're
working on which is task which is
classification so that's what we're
going to do we're going to grab this
model
and we're going to download it from the
hub we're going to configure it for
classification and we're going to apply
our data set to it
right
so just need to define a few parameters
here
i can load my data set again
different notebook
so that's the one we just saw
download it from the hub looking good
we can define a metrics function
to compute metrics during the training
job
and then we grab that distilbert model
and again this is a couple of lines of
code one line to grab the model one line
to grab the tokenizer
and
next we tokenize the training set and
the validation set
okay and that's not difficult at all
just again one line
and then we can configure our training
job okay
and
the underlying model here
we can see in the git repo
is a pi torch model right so you could
load it in pi torch and do the usual
stuff
and that's totally fine
um but if you want to keep it high level
and just go fast
you can use this trainer api in the
hogging face transformers library
and as you can see all it takes is
defining
a few hyper parameters
and then putting everything together in
the trainer api so what model am i
training what are the parameters
what tokenizer to use what metric to
compute during trading and of course the
two data sets
okay and then i just call train and this
is a gpu powered instance
so for simplicity i just trained it for
a single epoch
that's not nearly enough here but
okay it keeps the training time
reasonable
and once training com completes of
course i can see my different metrics
and i can evaluate the model
right
and once again i can just call hey push
to hub
right and now
if i open this thing
okay this push-to-hub api created all of
this
right it creates a new git repo on the
hugging face hub it uploads all the
model files
right and it creates this very nice
thing that we call the model card
you can see you know the metrics
you can see the hyper parameters
you can see the versions of the
different libraries we used
right
and the good thing about it is it's a
markdown file so i can go and edit it
and add my own stuff right my own
description if i wanted
right and that's good practice because
then you know anyone in your team
or in your company you know wanting to
use this they you know they know where
to start from which is kind of better
than a zip file somewhere on the on the
company server or you know
just uh just more detailed right
okay and now i've got this model on the
hub
and i can predict with it and i can
actually test it here
let's go and try that
okay and this will load the model on
demand on our infrastructure and predict
okay this is called the inference api
this is one of our
of our services this is the free version
that's integrated on the model page of
course we have a commercial version for
companies who want to have endpoints 24
7.
so let's give it a few seconds to load
all right
and we see that this is label four which
really means five stars remember because
we decremented everything
and of course it's a very positive
review
so you see how fast i'm doing this so
i'm going a little too fast in the
interest of time but you know you could
do this you know in your office in
couple of hours and get some you know
results and share results very very
quickly
okay um so yes we could use that model
to predict
just as usual
um we could also
deploy it just like i've done so here we
we used it on the model page
but actually you can load it on demand
programmatically and this is the same
thing right uh the the inference api
here
um so let me see if that works yeah okay
it's still it's still running on the
endpoint
right so just issuing that uh requests
that https request will load the model
on demand and predict so if the model is
not loaded yet it'll say something like
you know model loading come back in 20
seconds
so here it's the model is already live
so it's predicting right there
okay and there's nothing else this this
is deployment on the inference api
right no
you know
i mean i like terraform and cloud
formation just like everyone else
or not but to me this is kind of nice
right for devon test i don't see how we
could go faster than this
okay
all right let me yeah keep an eye on the
clock here we're good
um
so there you go uh
data prep model training model
deployment
did we actually write machine learning
code here seriously
yeah it's machine learning in the end
but did we did we actually go into
machine learning details no
right
just
grab some off the shelf bits and pieces
put them together with the trainer api
and
you know using the hugging face services
we're done
right so when i say you can experiment
deploy in a matter of hours and show
some results
you know
i don't think i'm making this up
honestly
so here's another bit you could be
interested in this is a new library we
recently uh kind of
expanded on it's called evaluate
and it makes it easy to
evaluate your models on different
metrics right which is usually something
you want to do very early on in the
project you have your let's say five
models that you want to
experiment with and you want to see how
they work against some data sets that
you have you know in the easiest
possible way
so here i'm just downloading my model
again from the hub same one we just saw
and loading my data set um
right that's the evaluation set the 10
000 samples
and i can see all the built-in metrics
in evaluate
and there are quite a few right
some of them pretty exotic
all built in and of course you can add
your own right you can expand if you
have custom custom metrics you can add
them to that library
and then it's just as easy as saying hey
you know load the accuracy metric
and
please compute accuracy on this model
right
passing the model the tokenizer the data
set
the name of the labels blah blah blah
right
and okay we get that result and you know
what's coming
we can push that stuff to the hub
okay because
and we probably see it here
yes
because you want to keep track of all
that work and all the on all those
experiments right and the model page
here is where you store all the
information on the model
so you could have evaluated the model on
i don't know 10 of your test sets and
very easily store the results and they
don't need to be in an excel sheet or
in some kind of complex platform out
there
you can have everything on that model
page right
so evaluate is pretty cool you have
other metrics
uh the the they work the same right so
go go check it out
okay so now we're
we're getting to the point where
hopefully we have a model that we like
right we find him the model the metrics
are okay
uh or okay at least for you know first
round of uh
maybe a b testing
and demoing
so
how about we build something that looks
like a demo
right
and you know
raise your hand if you've done like a
jupyter notebook demo to business people
who went huh
yeah yeah yeah all of you i'm sure okay
me too me too i've done that
and and you show them that right
it's like see see
that's a good model right there
and yeah and then yeah and
yeah
and if it's am they'll go for the
delivery order and if it's pm they'll go
for the
you know the bar selection process
uh but you've lost them okay
so instead of showing those very nice
tokens and attention masks which matter
to us right because we need to
understand that
how about we build something that looks
like something they can relate to and
understand
and this is called spaces
right
so all of you have been blindly playing
with dali mini and all those uh crazy
models and never quite looked at what's
what's happening under the hood here's
your chance okay
so spaces
is
obviously on the hugging face hub
and it's a very simple way to build a
demo app
a web app that we host
using either gradio which is actually
part of hogging face now or streamlit
okay
and
and you know uh
i'm not much of a ui guy you know the
last ui code i wrote was probably
1992 and i hated it
uh yeah i'm that old
and uh and so i thought oh no machine
learning ui you know what can go wrong
and you know and i actually managed to
do it and i actually enjoyed it which
was unexpected so you can go and play on
the hub with all those crazy models
i'm gonna show you the simplest example
right
and the simplest example goes something
like this
okay
so working with our good friend
that we fine tune here
how do we load it on a web page and make
it easy for business people to test but
we do this
we import the gradio framework and of
course transformers
we create a text classification pipeline
we create the simplest interface with an
input text box and an output text box
the input is obviously where we'll tap
the review the output is obviously where
we'll see the result and we'll have a
big nice button that will invoke the
predict function which obviously
passes
the text input
predicts it
and then we extract the label
uh
thing
and you know and we try to display as
many stars as that thing says plus one
okay and i'm sure there's a much better
way to do this but like i said
anytime i get near ui stuff you know
chaos happens so
so let's try and run this thing
and it's public so you can go and try it
here it is
so this is what it looks like
ah
aha
right
there you go
so how did i go from
this
to this
well the only thing i did was
create
a space repo on the hugging face hub
add
those 10 lines of python to it
push
wait for 30 seconds for the space the
space to go up
and that was it
and of course we can see this it's a git
repo and here's my file
i just pushed it right and it fired up
everything okay so now obviously this is
a trivial example in the interest of
time
we have some better ones
yeah we have time for it
okay
going off script i repeat
let's try this one
okay this one is a better one that i
built
it it will run voice queries on
financial documents
okay
so i'm gonna and it's gonna do
speech to text
translation and semantic search using
those two models sentence transformers
for semantic search and those nice
facebook models for
um speech text and translation
so let's try that
there's a lot of echo hopefully it's
going to work
okay so let me try and record something
here
okay
so it's going to do speech to text
translation to uh
oh yeah
nice um
it's going to do
a translation from french to english and
then it's going to do semantic search i
need to zoom out a little bit
so yeah yeah
and then it's going to run semantic
search on those uh snp 500 annual
reports to find the top matching
sentences
right
so imagine showing this to a business
owner instead of a silly complex
notebook especially with speech
right speech in notebooks is always a
little tricky
right
and and i i'll be honest i'm doing this
demo quite a lot for you know bank cxos
and they go blank for 60 seconds so
and then they ask okay how much
and yeah and that's where the
interesting discussion starts
okay how big is this
it's a
113 lines
with honestly a third of that being the
ui
and the rest is exactly what you think
it is loading the models building the
pipeline that's it okay
so you can it took me two days to do
this and you know i'm slow
so either anyone here can do this in you
know an afternoon of work once you know
how to you know once you've figured it
out
so space is is super powerful
i really really encourage you to go and
check it out
and you'll find spaces for
everything now right all the use cases
so go find something like looks like
your problem watch their code
and then uh hack it and build something
cool yeah
all right the last bit i want to show
you is
that big problem we mentioned okay so
now you've got your you've got your data
set and your fine tool model
and you've done your cxo demo
and it's like okay we want this thing in
production next week and and because you
promised it was agile because you
listened to that evangelist dude
and you didn't know better
and you deployed in prod and you know it
predicts in 900 milliseconds which is
way too slow for you okay
so
enter hardware acceleration
so i'll show you a couple of examples um
just on inference i won't go into
accelerating training because it's kind
of a session in itself i'll show you how
to use the onnx acceleration and i'll
show you how to use the intel
neural compressor acceleration which we
just launched literally last week
and you'll see it's not scary right
because every time you see hardware in a
room full of
data science people they they can tend
to go you mean you mean what i mean gpus
right you mean yeah you mean i just grab
them and use them right
and don't worry it's we don't need any
hardware skills
which i don't have either so it's
perfect
so what are we doing here um well we're
installing the optimum library we're
loading the model
same old model
and the first step is to convert it to
onnx which is a good step
because now you could go and deploy it
on any onnx compatible
model server
right so that's good to know in itself
of course we can predict with it it
works just fine
and this is the the dumbest benchmark
here okay it took 14 seconds to do 500
predictions
okay that's
that's a miserable way to benchmark
things but it gives us a sense of okay
what's the base the baseline is
so now we could say well can we optimize
this thing a little bit um
and we could just use we'll just trust
the o runtime which is very clever to do
the right thing
and so
we're loading the model again using this
ort or nx runtime optimizer object and
we're just exporting it
and we're setting the optimization level
to 99 which is very unsafe
it turns on everything
and uh could lead to disasters from time
to time
um
but in this case it it kind of works
okay so 99 means yeah everything
everything you can do on this model go
and do
and
now we have this optimized model which
we can load again we can still use that
very friendly pipeline object
and we can predict 500 times again and
you can see we went from 14 seconds to
less than less than 14 seconds okay
again this is a very crude way to
benchmark but clearly something happened
right we already saved some time here
and and we probably didn't hurt accuracy
too much we would probably need to check
right
if we want to go a little crazier we can
do quantization so quantization who's
not familiar with quantization
okay a few folks all right fine
so quantization means
you replace your
floating point 32-bit parameters
with eight-bit integers
and now everybody goes what no
you know what do you mean i trained for
three weeks
you know i wanted all those 32-bit
values now you're taking them away
well i'm taking them away because
obviously 8-bit integer arithmetic is
quite faster than
32-bit floating-point arithmetic
it's going to shrink the model as well
make it smaller you know so less memory
usage faster compute
and it's really you know you need to
strike a balance between how much you
want to shrink it and how fast you want
to make it right
and you
and how much accuracy you're ready to
lose in the process you know maybe
you're ready to lose you know one
percent if you can make the model 10
times a lot smaller right
so we just do this and here we're
running on a cpu machine i'm so we're
optimizing for the
intel chips with this fancy avx 512
instruction set which is basically
designed to accelerate you know
multiply and accumulate operations that
are very
frequent in deep learning
and we just do this and save the model
again and we can see the model did
shrink quite a lot we shrunk it from 256
megs to 165 megs
so that's that's pretty impressive
and predicting again we see yeah there
is a very significant speed up again
right
okay
and again you would need to run much
better benchmark but this is just
showing right a couple of lines of code
can have a large impact on on the
inference performance
you would still need to run
you know your evaluation data set
against this to make sure you didn't
lose 10 accuracy
right um
which is which is possible sometimes
but generally you know optimum makes it
simple to do this thing
um
an alternative to using on nx is again
this new collaboration we have with
intel
they have this tool called the intel
neural compressor which does similar
things you know quantization
it works pretty much the same
here it is
loading the model passing a config file
and quantizing
what's interesting here is you can
actually set a target you can say hey i
don't want to lose more than one percent
accuracy
right i think in this instance it says
three percent
okay so quantize but don't drop the
accuracy more than three percent and it
will actually iterate on the
quantization efforts until it's within
budget
so in this instance i got very lucky
because
on the first round it actually hit that
target
and
the uh
the metric actually improved a little
bit right we can see the baseline
accuracy and we see the quantized
accuracy
so sometimes accuracy will go up a
little bit
because quantization helps
fight
overfitting in a lot of cases so i guess
i just got lucky okay
right the only thing i did was this
right so again you don't need to know
the first thing about the the hardcore
details of hardware optimization right
it's very very easy to use
okay
all right so i think now we've covered
most of the uh
most of the spectrum
okay
uh most of the spectrum here
you know data sets models training
optimize uh building demos with spaces
optimizing
so you know now it's your turn to play
right so where do you go next
uh well i guess you go to the hugging
face hub right and sign up takes 30
seconds it's completely free obviously
if you're completely new um i guess the
best entry points are the tasks
where the the devrel team has built lots
of really interesting content on
explaining what those nlp and computer
vision and
speech tasks are what does it mean to do
you know speaker separation what does it
mean to to do zero shot classification
in plain english
and then you can go and take the hugging
face course which which is awesome
honestly
they also the same folks also published
a book on aurelie on transformers i
highly recommend it and if you have
questions
you can just go to the forum and ask all
the questions the whole company is
reading and answering so
you know don't be shy
and if you have production workloads
and you like to go to the next level
obviously we can help and we got to make
a living too
so
we can provide expert support on all the
on the whole scope from picking models
to you know optimizing latency down to
crazy low numbers
and
if you work for a regulated company like
a bank or an insurance company or a life
census company or maybe public sector
and you have to run everything on
infrastructure that you manage
um you know we can help with that
because everything you saw here we can
also deploy on your own infrastructure
in the cloud or on-prem okay so you can
get in touch right
well that's what i wanted to to tell you
today so you know it's a whirlwind tour
of hugging face
june 2022
we're running pretty fast
and you know we want to keep building
good stuff
for the community and for customers as
well
so
hope you like it and if you need help
later on don't hesitate and get in touch
okay thanks a lot